we had a story from the post-millennial
DeSantis loses 10 points Trump gains 13
in latest CNN SSRS presidential poll
that's great now that I'm a big fan of
CNN polling you know but it's it's a
data point is a new poll conducted by
CNN just days before DeSantis announced
that he would be formally announcing
they you know we can see that his
numbers are dropping according to the
poll
uh 53 of Republicans voters say they
would consider themselves as currently
supporting Trump while DeSantis guarded
only 26 percent compared to the previous
data set collected between March 8th to
through the 12th DeSantis lost 10 points
while Trump gained 13. yeah I I am
telling you when a lot of things that
Trump has been doing have been boosting
him in the polls and me personally I I'm
like I like what he's doing going to
Ohio yes East Palestine that was
absolutely fantastic doing the
McDonald's bed like I know the menu
better than you guys
and the funny thing is you want to win
the presidency you need good policies
but you are not selling someone look
let's put it this way
if you're selling a refrigerator to
somebody and you knock on their door and
say my refrigerator's got 200 watts of
pure power with my refrigerator if
someone else walks up and says you want
the best refrigerator you've ever seen
in your life boom there it is look at
that thing shiny and beautiful
yeah yeah obviously you need real
policies yes but Trump is the the
he's the crazy guy he's the loud he's
he's the the loud man the salesman and
the Santa says the numbers guy well and
this is important right because what
people are going to say is what's
important is the quality of the
refrigerator guys we're all trying to
sell the same refrigerator the question
is who's the better salesman
Trump's Trump's refrigerator might be a
little bit worse maybe I mean we we saw
uh swamp monsters we saw John Bolton
he's made some bad look I'm not saying
Trump is perfect I guess my main point
with all of this is when I see a poll
that says DeSantis is falling I don't
regard this with joy this doesn't make
me happy it's not like when Trump was
crushing Jeb Bush or these other
politicians who I really dislike it it's
not enjoyable for me because I do like
DeSantis I don't think this rivalry is
good for the Republican party I think
it's bad for the conservative movement
but I'd be look I'd be lying if I sat
her and said DeSantis is just as
charismatic and Trump and Injustice
capable of exciting people because it's
not true let's do the analogy this way
you've got roommates or family members
and we've all got to agree on which
refrigerator we're gonna get yeah and
you got Rhonda santis Trump and Joe
Biden Joe Biden's refrigerator is like
from the 60s it's broken completely and
he can't even tell you what's going on
come on man he's just like all right you
don't have questions he directs you to
Kamala Harris yeah I don't know what
this is and then Ron is giving you this
very very straightforward quiet Lope
and then Trump is giving you this loud
boisterous we're gonna have the best
refrigerator mark my words and
everyone's like yeah yeah screaming I
want that one yeah well but hold on and
there's an important Point here which is
someone could hear that analogy and
still think I would choose the better
fridge and not the better salesman okay
that's true you would but this isn't a
question of us picking a fridge for our
house this is a question of us picking a
refrigerator salesman to sell the fridge
to the entire country collectively
exactly what are people going to buy
like what are people gonna buy and I
think part of the criticism of trump is
always oh he's not dignified he's not
presidential enough but I think that's
why people relate to him he doesn't fit
a mold he's exciting he's funny he's
relatable in the same way that JFK was
sort of this young like breath of fresh
air to his era and he Jerusalem people I
think people are drawn to Trump because
he represents strength and not having to
conform with the kind of stodgy
Republican Party of the past I think
people like that uh change of pace
knowing that they can send him to talk
to Vladimir Putin you can send him out
into the world he will make you know
he's not 100 perfect all the time but he
does come through on a lot of his
promises and that's what people want
I'll tell you the most important point
Ron desantis's accomplishments are
bolstered by a republican legislature
that sends him the bills that he can
sign and if he goes to the presidency
unless the Republicans win every Branch
he won't have that what we need and what
I think we need to be able to rely on is
not policy but executive action firing
bureaucrats agreed getting rid of the
deep State yeah criminal day one on day
one day one by the way immediately I I
feel confident that my best path towards
that is Donald Trump
Rhonda Sanders can come out and say
policy policy policy and I'll say how
are you going to get any of those
policies done with Democrats that's
right obstructing unless of course in
2024 Republicans win both houses both uh
Chambers which we have a shot at
absolutely if that's the case well so
then policy matters but if we're talking
about the best path forward it's going
to be we hedge our bets we want the best
case scenario and that is Trump may not
have the best policies because right
attendance really does have a great list
of policies though it's pretty good he's
good and going forward policy is the
best the best we've ever seen right but
Ronda santis his policies are actually
the Florida State Legislature it's not
just him so we don't know what we're
going to get with with the president
DeSantis it's real so my point is you
want policies vote for Congress vote
Republicans into Congress in the senate
make sure they win there and then Trump
signs whatever they give them right
we're talking about the presidency the
executive action we're not talking about
the legislature so but it's not just any
executive action it's executive action
for the first time we literally electing
a lame duck president on day one
oh man so he is completely unencumbered
by anything he is free yeah to do
literally whatever he wants on day one
yeah and the next two and a half years
it's all his show because he can't get
reelected that's exactly what we want
yeah we don't want anybody married to
the past we don't want anybody married
to any of three letter agencies it was
sort of what he struggled with in his
first term which is that how do I how do
I do both how do I get my second term he
doesn't have to do both yeah and that's
exactly what the country wants exactly
the country exactly yeah yeah and then
whoever his vice president is wherever
that person that he picks is going to be
that's going to be a very important
person to move on to take his policies
for the future to get Republicans
reelected then but I cannot imagine a
world that we don't want him walking in
on day one and signing 167 executive
executive orders overturning the
disaster that Biden has been for the
previous four years that's exactly what
the country wants right now and that's
why he's doing so well in the polling
and you were saying that he can't pick
uh DeSantis via's vice president I know
a lot of people have floated at Trump to
Santa's ticket but they're full from
Florida multiple reasons they're both
from Florida for multiple reasons he's
running I mean this is a loyalty issue I
mean president Trump is big on loyalty
uh this this level of disloyalty really
takes him out of that competition and
also both being from Florida and we need
every single Electoral College vote
going to 2024 as possible so yeah so who
do you think he's going to pick who
would you try to be his VP do not tell
president Donald John Trump
nobody tells him nobody tells him what
to do but if you could make a suggestion
who would be your pick for VP I actually
today I had a few ideas a few months ago
and today
I actually have no idea the issue that
we have to take we have to take into
account to is you are absolutely right
you were talking earlier about the
general election and we're talking about
Suburban women and how we're going to
lose a lot of them kind of kind of no
matter what for a sundry of different
reasons what I like looking at and
focusing on is the growth that we have
seen
the black community
specifically black men
I'll put a clip up a couple of days ago
about Ice Cube and I'm talking Ice Cube
like like Mr NWA like Cube literally
railing on the Democrat Party and saying
that Democrats have been in charge for
the past 40 years and they have done
absolutely nothing for the black
community in the last 40 years and then
I saw some other polling that had
Joe Biden down 40 points amongst black
men wow I want to point to 2020 a couple
of years ago president Trump got the
highest vote the highest percentage of
votes for black men and modern history
for a republican at 18.7 percent if he
is able to ask retains 25 or more those
Suburban white women that we may not
pick up will be will be supplemented by
black men that do and will vote for
president Trump moving forward and when
I see Cube leaving I'm like this is
getting very interesting yeah and and
um obviously if black men are choosing
Trump these these liberal women they're
racist unless they do unless they do
they need to listen to uh the voice of
the marginalization people have to
listen to people of color their lived
experience right right so tell us what
to do and how to think I'm hinting that
uh Tim Scott from South Carolina is the
best choice for VP I think he would have
a yeah I think he has a fair shot I
think think again anybody that's not
from Florida we'll we'll have to see
kind of who shakes out but literally I'm
not going to even begin we want to guess
I can't I can't I literally can't guess
uh I think that's going to be solely up
to president Trump and I think he's
going to pick a great person he'll pick
the right person
um and I again a few months ago I
absolutely would have guessed but then
now you're seeing people running against
him and I don't know how he is going to
handle that in the long run yeah it'll
be interesting again that's why I was
lit with two like you don't tell him
what to do I mean let's let's just be
honest I like Tim Scott he's a good guy
yeah and and you I think we talked about
so much before the show but one of the
points was
it won't be DeSantis because he wants an
advantage in another state so any other
any other person that's um announcement
video had much more power I mean you're
saying that Santa's came off confused
and sort of timid and tired that's not
the case with what what Tim Scott it was
not the case I'd also like to ask
something
um just pertaining to what you said a
moment ago did you say that Trump got
the historic percentage of the black
vote in 2016 or 2020. that was it was 20
25 2020. okay okay
it was not up from 2016. yes it went
down from 2016 and I'm also I'm talking
specifically about black men black men
18.7 of black men and I found that the
fascinating stat because that's
literally how we make up the difference
I'm convinced of that at this point I
think uh Wall Street General ran a story
saying that if the Democrats dip below
80 of the black vote they can't win it's
it's actually mathematically impossible
yeah because that's their base literally
that's their base it's even just 21
Republicans just win that's it yeah
that's it and that's why if you look at
what happened
I'm sorry I'm so sorry to interrupt I
just read a piece of information that
shocked me you said if it goes below 80
the Democrats can't win because 80
percent of black men supported Joe Biden
which was down from Hillary at 82
percent it looks like they're but
they're probably right they're really
approaching that it's trending and by
the way he's doing abysmally Joe Biden
right now is doing abysmally bad amongst
black men today and I think it's it's
it's a bunch of reasons why I mean it's
always inflation it's always the economy
when I'm in a barber shop man it's it's
absolutely hilarious to to listen to
people that were before like I can't
stand Trump I can't stand Trump and now
they're like actually
I kind of I kind of really wish I had
that that's some interesting stuff now
it's really interesting and it's it's a
it's a change imagine you have to raise
the price of every hair that you every
head that you cut and then that eats
into your gas money gas money gas money
is up inflation is up and then less if
fewer people come get their hair cut
because it's more expensive and now
they're looking around they're like just
get get me back to the way it was when
President Trump was here yeah well it's
also wild to see how quickly this
dropped the figures I'm having here
showed that black people black men voted
for Obama at a rate about 95 by the time
it was on to Hillary Clinton it was 82
percent I gotta say the fact that
firstly the fact that fewer black men
voted for Biden than Hillary
what what appeal I could sort of
understand like Biden was with the Obama
campaign so there's an identity politics
angle there and but we'll do tend to
vote Democrat for sure overwhelmingly
like who who genuinely feels that
Hillary Clinton cares about the black
community it's shocking me that anyone
in America does well because she doesn't
and quite frankly neither does Joe Biden
but at the time of over Hillary was a
vote against Trump and I I yeah I get
that it's it's still it's still shocking
me that that many blocks the time before
they knew better yeah yeah but it's also
shocking to me that like Joe Biden got
even less of the black mouth out than
Hillary did
yeah I think they're scared I mean you
could probably speak to this but there
is a disenfranchisement from a lot of
different groups but with black men with
a Democratic party because it has failed
them on so many levels exactly exactly
and it's always the economy and I was
talking to this is really funny actually
I was talking to a buddy Iman he's from
Atlanta and he is absolutely going to
vote for president Trump here in 2024
and he said it'll be the first time I've
a republican but I voted for Trump he
started a company he's doing well he
just started making money he was the
first person to go to college in his
family he's beginning to make some
generational wealth and he told me he
goes bruh
I just got this money and you want to
tax that 50 and I'm just now getting
those eagas you lost me at I'm going to
raise ta I'm going to raise
I'm out I'm out and so you're looking at
kind of this next generation of people
that are like yeah this just isn't
working out for me like it like it had
been in the past or like I was told it
was supposed to work out and again this
is why you don't ever give Your
Allegiance as a body to any one thing or
to any one group ever when I talk to a
lot of my black friends as well they
don't care about Republican or Democrat
they don't they don't care anymore is
this is actually like not even a thing
what they want is government to work for
them and their best interest and they
don't want to feel like they're just
being overlooked and thrown to the side
and the rising tide raises all boats and
they want to be treated just like
everybody else and to be better off
before but better off now than they were
before well I just can't understand this
you know being from Chicago having a
hundred years of democrat rules right
and problem after problem after problem
nothing ever getting solved I have to
wonder if what's actually happening is
that people who get who people who grew
up in Chicago eventually just give up on
the political system or leave and then
the young people who are there are like
it'll change when I'm old enough and I
can vote and it doesn't they keep voting
for the same policies the same people
I'm wondering at what point in the
United States does the black community
say hey wait a minute the Democrats
actually haven't done anything for us
so they've also gotten away with
painting the Republican party as being
racist yeah and then someone like me
comes around decides to run for Congress
so let's talk about my district back in
Houston Texas I live in a district that
President Trump would have won by 23
points I ended up winning by 30 points
in the Republican primary I beat out
nine white guys in the general election
I beat out a white guy by 30 points
Trump plus 20 District I'll perform the
president I'd like to say that every now
and again by a little vet uh and it's a
white majority District in the
Republican primary 75 percent of the
voters were white and they voted for me
overwhelmingly and why because I was the
best candidate that's it that's
literally what our party is I get to
wake up every day and live Martin Luther
King's dream I'm literally being judged
by the content of my character not by
the color of my skin so people like me
come around and we look around I'm just
like actually I'm just here because I
just want to better America I don't even
view myself as black or African-American
first first of all I'm an American I'm a
combat veteran I am a father I am a West
Point graduate I'm an Ivy League
graduate and we can go all the way down
the line before I get to Black
I try to be I'm a father I'm all these
things and I like the idea of our party
not playing identity politics anymore
and then realizing that you see people
like me you see people like Byron
Donalds you see people like Senator
Scott we are all winning in white
majority areas by the way people so you
can't call us racist anymore Obama won
twice
oh the white supremacist country that
had a black president it's weird two
times twice no other country in the
entire world would elect a minority to
be the head of their country twice by
Boy wait by beating a Vietnam war hero
yeah and the clintons
and Mitt Romney who's like the liliest
like whitest dude ever he's the head of
the Mormon Church
gets no wider than that you know what I
mean do you get pushed away for being a
Republican all the time all the time
what do you say or like your kids ever I
guess they're pretty young but I love it
yeah I love it fuels you like the
conflict oh I love it because I'm
antithetical to the to the person that
I'm supposed to be yeah they look at
somebody like me and they're
automatically assume that I'm a Democrat
and they don't ask any questions about
my background or anything like that and
then if you actually heard my background
you knew where I came from you come from
military family grew up in a church you
find out very quickly why would this guy
be a Democrat no exactly
so but this is do that not Republicans
this is a very real thing right so I
lived in I live in Georgia I've lived in
Georgia about the past eight years now
the the area that I'm in has a high
black population and this could just be
because most of the friends I make are
through my Social Circle at church but
they're not socially liberal people by
any means and if you look at the polling
data especially on gay and trans issues
black people are far more conservative
than white people
the black community oftentimes has
allowed the benevolent white liberal to
convince them that they have more in
common than they think when in actuality
they have nothing in common
now what they'll tell the black
community is black lives matter and
we're we're here for you and we're here
to give give people handouts and give
you stuff that's what they say all the
time but by black lives matter the only
thing they they do is change their
Facebook profile picture to Black a
black Square they don't do anything
they've never done anything for black
people they don't even have black
friends would you think that some of
their policies
white person goes I have black friends
the reason they get mad at that isn't
because that's not an argument Against
Racism but it's not true for them none
of them know any black people they
actually don't 95 94 95 crime Bill Joe
Biden
disproportionately put black people
black men specifically in prison for
cocaine versus crack wine because
cocaine was the more affluent White Drug
crack was not and you at
you know I said a city hearing oh my
gosh that's brutal shout out to
Notorious BIG he famously said when
talking about the only way to get out
the hood he goes either you're slaying
crack rock or you got a wicked jump shot
Hunter Biden has no jump shot
but he be slanging crack rock oh man and
and so Hunter and so Joe Biden is
responsible for that legislation that
disproportionately locked up black
people and yet he is now the president
for the for for the group of people that
black people overwhelmingly vote for
that's a joke to me I'll I'll phrase
something very somewhat unfairly but are
you helping a child when the child
screams that they want more ice cream
are you helping them by giving them ice
cream or are you helping them by having
them go out exercise yeah do some
push-ups with you look
kids are gonna be like I don't want to
eat my vegetables that's right and you
say you got to eat your vegetables
because we need it for you it's good for
you and I feel like what ends up
happening often with the Republicans
versus the Democrats that the Democrats
will offer you the ice cream with extra
fudge and the Republicans will offer
reparations exactly but they never
actually do it but they can't do it they
dangle it right and the Republicans say
something like we're going to give you
the ability to work hard so you can
fulfill your dreams and then all of
these voters are not singling on any
rights I mean there's all of the people
who vote Democrat are just like I don't
want to work I'm we're seeing polls now
gen Z doesn't want to work crazy it's
well I'm not surprised but I don't
understand what else you do with your
life yes I want to make one point you
said that what Republicans say you know
the Democrats say we're going to give
you free stuff and the Republicans say
we're gonna give you good policy so you
can work hard and live out your dreams
it tends to be more like the Democrats
going we're gonna give you free stuff
and the Republicans going we're going to
passcode
exactly yeah I mean it's it's like what
we're saying is our like what we're
saying is already more boring in a sense
even though it's more reasonable and
then we say it in a boring way on top of
it to be fair they do also have people
like Nancy
pelosiers
and Schumer right and they're they're
not very you know charismatic at all but
neither is Mitch McConnell but yeah no
what I tend to see is it's like Mom
versus Dad it's Dad being like look you
gotta mow the lawn life's not fair yes
but it builds character it makes you
stronger makes you more capable and then
the Democrats of the mountain being like
us to get an ice cream that's it yep
that's it but well to be fair the mom
never shows up with the ice cream that's
exactly right she just says and that's
exactly you know it kind of kind of back
to the argument they know that they are
hemorrhaging black male voters and so
now what's what's the push now more free
stuff
by giving them free stuff and now I
think we're getting to the point to
where we're not falling for it anymore
like I don't I don't believe you you're
exactly right you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna promise US ice cream and
then you're not gonna deliver it the
reparations thing comes around every
every four years every four years well
this is this is what they're doing while
they're panicking remember this is the
level of pandering
it's like Pelosi had the scarf I wanted
Pelosi and all the Democrats were
kneeling and they had those like African
scarves on it was ridiculous okay come
on come on now
I think that Democrats are running out
of free stuff to offer the outweigh the
the cons right like their voters can see
that there's there is nothing in these
promises even if you get a mod a small
amount of money or some kind of benefit
ultimately your community is still
hurting and this is true for a lot of
people across the US that's correct uh I
mean the example we always get is uh the
effect social welfare has had on the
black family which has been horrible
it's been awesome all Democrat policies
by the way yeah because they hate the
family it's not just the black family
they hate all families they want you to
be dependent on the government so I'm
here right now in my family I talk to my
family we all go to West Point we all
served our country why is that I had two
parents my parents did not play games my
parents made sure that we went to church
they cared about where we went to school
and by the way this isn't like about
black or white people this is about like
you show me any individual that grew up
in the house like I grew up in
regardless of of the color of their skin
functioning nuclear family yes and well
and this is huge right because
oh they've wanted to I mean from the
get-go right because on some level their
values are satanic they hate the family
they hate anything that requires love or
any level of goodness I don't think they
conceive of it that way logically but
family bothers them and when you look at
the data the white family is
unfortunately very much catching up to
those rates of illegitimacy uh the the
rates are increasing everywhere now with
out of wedlock births and fatherless
homes and one thing not a lot of people
consider is that with the black family
falling apart and then the white family
following
this is often linked to social welfare
policies and that played a role but the
Brookings Institute released a pretty
interesting analysis where they were
attributing it to abortion and Roe v
Wade and the removal of the social
expectation that pregnancy meant you
were going to have a child and that the
man should be there to take care of the
child interesting that's correct yeah I
mean no but also in more democratic
policies but also another like
unfathomably evil Democratic policy like
yes let's kill babies then Sheamus just
goes yeah so so and then there's again
the disproportionate impact that it has
on a black community one in three
abortions are at the hands of a black
woman one in three and yet we are 13 of
the population now look I don't care if
you're a pro-life or pro-choice you
cannot be satisfied with the
disproportionate amount of a group of
people not existing on this Earth
because we have a culture that allows
that to happen that's a problem and
Democrats won't talk about that in New
York City yeah black babies more likely
to be aborted there are more in New York
City there are more aborted black babies
than born and Margaret Sanger was clear
about why she was starting Planned
Parenthood by the way very quickly
crystal clear this ignorance do you ever
see the commercial that Lena Dunham was
in and she's like yeah there's some
sketchy history but
it's like saying like Nazi Germany had
some sketchy stuff going like she was an
opening Genesis she was an open
eugenicist who wanted to eliminate what
she saw as lesser races yes
my single child-free life she obviously
cares about back to your point too about
how you say things and how you make
arguments as well and why the Democrats
are very good at this yeah so we
overturned Roe v Wade the only thing
that happened over turning Roe v Wade in
the Dobbs case was that we returned the
issue back to the individual states we
live in a constitutional republic that's
how this whole thing works all we did
that's all we did we didn't ban anything
with what the Democrats do no that's
that's a mouthful Republicans we live in
a constitutional republic and the only
thing that we did was return the rights
matters which is true what did they say
women's rights you hate women well you
see what uh they ran on that and they
won on that and Republicans that's not
true I think it's crazy that uh I don't
want you to have to murder your child is
hating them well also and Republicans
retreated right because they just
assumed people weren't going to be
willing to side with them on the
pro-life message so instead of hating
the messaging as hard as they possibly
could to be persuasive they tried to
hide from the fact that Roe was
overturned it's like you guys just did
the one effective thing I've seen
Republicans do in 20 years and you're
not going to bring that up when you're
running for office like we've had a
massive Victory and you're not going to
talk about that because you're scared
some people won't like it that was a
massive blunder in mind well I thought
it was where Donald Trump struggled a
little bit and I agreeable with CNN
because they were trying to push him
would you uh you know federally ban
abortion whatever he should have just
said it's a state's issue we saw that no
like just hit that point over and over
again it's a state's rights issue what
they should have said was based yes I
will
but you know what I mean
so when Trump was asked about by Megan
Kelly about calling women fat pigs he
says
he didn't run away from it he owned it
yeah Republicans should be like yeah
actually we did support president Trump
we are glad to see the states now have
the right to pass legislation exactly
and you may notice that in many of the
blue States they've been more accepting
and uh permissive of abortion and in red
states where the majority of the people
that's called democracy isn't it if you
don't like it you can vote with your
feet and you live in a different state
that's more palatable to your beliefs
right but you you own it and you explain
to people why when the Republicans hide
from it it creates the impression that
it was the wrong thing to do and they're
ashamed of it well I think we have to
own it in a much different way I hear
what you're saying about the fact the
Democrats are going this is about
women's rights the Republicans should be
saying this is about children's rights
or babies rights or not allowing babies
to die but instead because Republic
Democrats aren't saying well Federal
power is being challenged so for the
answer to be will states have rights now
is the wrong long response they're going
at this from the angle of making it a
very emotional issue and they should
they should because it is emotional and
that's how you persuade people boom but
Republicans won't Republicans are like
let's have a conversation about the
legal precedent that allowed for this to
occur and why you should be okay with it
come on the average person doesn't care
do you think that there's an effective
way for Republicans to argue this issue
emotionally I feel like so awesome yes I
feel like it's like the easiest one to
argue babies are dying yeah but they'll
say well it's not a baby it's not real
don't argue a fetus argue a baby yes so
I recognize that but I feel like any
moderate who leans left or Progressive
would say like you guys are being crazy
no no Republicans are just bad at what
they do yeah I told the story before but
you know it Bears repeating for our
Congressman Frontier a friend of mine
who's a liberal in New York City not
very politically active but just kind of
a normie when when Democrats were voting
on the uh restrictionless abortion I
think it was it was Colorado but there
was also a Democrat Bill federally that
would allow abortion at any stage of
pregnancy if there was a medical issue
and when I brought this up and said
there's a whole lot we can get into is
pertaining to the medical issue point
but it does allow for terminating the
life of a baby that can survive on its
own and he said that's not true they
would never do that and I grabbed my
phone and I pulled it up I said read
that line and he reads and he goes
something's not right something that
can't be correct and I said well look
whether you think I'm right or wrong let
me ask you do you think that a woman
let's say let's say she can't have the
baby should they like find a way to
deliver that baby and remove it let it
live or should they just kill him he's
like well yeah they should find any way
they can have the baby live but but I
think they're saying that like if the
woman can't carry the baby anymore she
can have an abortion because of a
medical issue and I said
so in the circumstance where the baby
can survive and the pregnancy can be
terminated and the mother saved why kill
the baby and he was just like I I don't
believe that there's something's wrong
something right here and so the point is
regular people need to hear that yeah
that's the position from where
Republicans should be arguing saying
like look when Donald Trump was asked
about banning abortion he gave a
brilliant answer he says it depends on
where the deal is some people think six
weeks some people think eight weeks
we'll have to see what the deal is the
compromise he is a deal maker yeah and I
think that's what the American people
need to be told it's we're not talking
about forcing women to give birth or
whatever that weird nonsense line is it
doesn't really make sense anyway makes
no sense there is a baby the baby is in
the woman now let's try and protect the
rights of the woman and the child if the
child can survive on its own I ask you
this why would we permit it to be killed
perfect
so and I'll add this obviously everyone
know everyone here knows my stance on
abortion the audience does completely
against it I think the Republican party
needs to be completely against it that
said when you look at the way the
parties operate as they currently stand
the Republican position is anywhere
ranging from no abortion should ever be
allowed which base that's the correct
take two there should be some
restrictions on abortion the Democratic
position is there should be zero
restrictions on abortion that is the
actual Democratic party and that's
insane completely I mean that is your
average person absolutely that's insane
in Colorado up to birth yes which which
means based on that definition your
average person is far more in line with
the Republican approach here and and I'm
a good example of that and we've had a
couple different leftists on this show
and the funny thing about the
conversation is that they know they
can't answer it without looking bad so
they try to wiggle around the answer but
I say do you think a woman should be
able to terminate a viable baby to kill
it to abort it at nine months and they
go well I mean you got understand we're
talking about no no no no simple
question and they go yes she said it's
her body and I'm like there it is that's
crazy it is that's if that's that's
crazy if the baby has to come out of the
woman it's there why kill it in the
process right because that's the whole
point perhaps yeah it's the whole point
if it wasn't a human they wouldn't be
killing it and this is the problem I
have because I I come from a Libertarian
uh perspective on this pertaining to
government rights and limitations right
and recognize we've got human two human
lives we're dealing with the left seems
to just say whatever they want to say so
they can get the right to kill the baby
with no accountability for the other
life right zero
I'm reminded of uh Governor Bill
Lindsley of Washington he sent this
letter to Idaho's Governor Brad little
saying uh I'm asking you to veto your
abortion trafficking law and this was uh
Littles the law on like if you transport
a minor out of state for an abortion
without telling your parents you are in
trouble uh he was like because if the
women of Washington travel to your state
and have to get an abortion you will
persecute them it's like yes why would
they travel across the border to that
when Washington is a pro-abortion state
but instead it's like because you might
affect my government your government
must change to fit my rules thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time